well Ben Shapiro is the editor-in-chief
of The Daily wire syndicated columnist
and still chuckles at that video that
we've been watching for the last week
commemorating the one year since Donald
Trump shocked the world and and won the
election then why do you laugh I mean if
one thing could make president Trump's
presidency work that it's that video
that some Republicans were screaming to
or screaming yeah well I think that's
true but the reaction of the left to to
Trump's presidency and really over the
last two years I think in in the run-up
to the election has been so extreme that
it wasn't really a surprise to see
people screaming at this guy I'm not
sure how they think it's going to help
but yeah there are a number of Democrats
who are just screaming at the TV every
time Donald Trump comes on television
and in fact there are some House
Democrats we're gonna launch another
swing at impeachment later today I can't
imagine what they're thinking if they
were actually to succeed in impeaching
Trump let's say that they were to win
the house next year and probably not win
the Senate so the impeachment doesn't go
through so they reach but they don't
actually convict in the Senate that
would be the stupidest thing that could
possibly do because nothing would rally
Trump's base quite like an impeachment
over charges that have yet to be
specified again I'm not sure exactly on
what grounds that are preaching him they
actually have to provide some sort of
grounds for for getting rid of otherwise
too much tweeting yeah I guess that
would be at right well you see the
fantasy spot that Tom Steyer bought a
bawd saying that looking at all the
things he's done so out three two-thirds
of which is pre Orphic pure fiction but
people believe it well I think people
believe what they want to believe in
these situations I mean the left is
still focused on the idea that Trump
somehow stole the election in collusion
with Russia and that that's not wishful
thinking than it is reality
the better the better move for the
Democrats seems to be happening actually
in hellas which is that they're throwing
hillary clinton under the bus piece by
piece and doing that moving away from
this election cycle I think is probably
their best hope for regaining power the
longer they're stuck in relitigate in
2016 election the worse it is for them
better it is for president Trump I've
been looking at your day planner you're
supposed to go to Tufts University to
give a talk but they're trying to pull
the the funding for the security I heard
something like that I know a lot of the
the left students have been protesting
and yelling at the administration
suggesting that I create an unsafe
environment this is sort of how do you
do that
I don't know I don't seem that
physically imposing to me but it's but
apparently all the things that I say
particularly when I talk about the idea
that men are men and women are women
when I talk about America being a
country of individualism where white
privilege is not the rule
that when I say these things it makes
people feel insulted and they get very
fun well maybe it's because to the
students there they feel that that is
their safe place and you should not
invade it yes I think that they've
really conflated my different politics
with me insulting their identity it's
one of the most dangerous things that's
happening politically in the country is
this idea that if I disagree with you
it's not a disagreement over the issues
or over what we believe it's a
disagreement with with you as a human
use it goes back to tolerance unless you
feel differently than we do
how many colleges have refused for you
or you've had a situation like this a
hiccup where you weren't able to talk
well I mean is there a bunch of colleges
yeah that's a Berkeley there was a
university Wisconsin we had protesters
that held up the speech so much that the
legislature actually passed a bill we
had a Cal State Los Angeles where there
was a near-riot DePaul University
threatened to arrest me if I if I
stepped on campus I was invited by the
students and then the administration
that was literally standing in front of
their security chief and they brought in
the Cook County Sheriff and they said if
you take one more step we'll arrest well
let's talk about with Tufts we're tough
said here's what the student action in
Tufts United for immigrant justice
Facebook event said bench beards history
of spreading fake news and
fear-mongering particularly around
issues of immigration has put many of
our communities int an intangible
amounts of danger if Ben Shapiro invited
to campus he will be given a legitimate
platform to continue spreading these
lies that says you even recognize that
descriptive is your dangerous I mean no
and that's also a pretty astonishing
statement particularly that my
statements on immigration I mean I've
been for a while I'm for immigration
enforcement but my actual position on
immigration is to increase legal
immigration and to ensure that the
people who are here we assess on a case
by case basis and put them at the back
of the line if we think they should stay
and throw them out if we think they
ought to go but that doesn't seem like a
particularly hardline position even by
kind of normal political men show you
personally I don't get insulted as much
as as much as bemused
I'm sort of confused as to why exactly
people are so exercised over me showing
up on their campus but in a perverse way
the controversy is probably good for
your personal brand
Oh Ben Shapiro he's a troublemaker we
want to hear from ya I think that's
right i mean we're packing lecture
lecture halls across the country I mean
we're showing up in lecture halls of a
thousand two thousand people and we're
packing them I spoke at UCLA the other
night and it was a 600 person hall but
they had 1,400 people who had registered
beyond that so if people are interested
in hearing the message that the
stupidest thing that the left can do is
do to me the exact same thing they've
done the President Trump you know go
overboard and make the issue about me as
opposed to make the issue about the
issue we're pretty good source that says
you're also again rejected at Syracuse
even though the Republican Party wants
you to come the administration doesn't
and then that wouldn't be surprising at
all I mean they don't want the
controversy they don't want what they
perceived to be the security risk even
though the past few lectures I've done
there really hasn't been any opposition
at all I mean at Berkeley there were 600
police officers and you know some
members of antifoam that was about it
where do you stand on Roy Moore do you
think you should be seated if wins and
no I don't think she'd be seeing it if
it was huge think that he is not worthy
yes I think I think it's a disaster for
the Republican Party if a man who has
credible allegations that he is not
rebutted of child molestation is seated
as a senator well we know you're gonna
be seated at noon on another curvy couch
doing outnumbered today right yeah
looking forward to it all right I
believe that you believe that by the way
somebody on our crew listens to your
podcast whenever you put it out if you
haven't heard it go to iTunes or
SoundCloud any of the apps yeah thank
you